and not McGinnis we really appreciate as
you taking the time to speak to us on
Sky News this afternoon
the loss of an extraordinary politician
and is really summed up by your
relationship with it you went from very
fierce political opponents to being very
close friends
yes so I'm obviously very sad to hear
that the inn has died and I want to
extend my deepest and heartfelt sympathy
to Aileen
Paisley his wife and to his family he
and I I suppose will be recognized as
two people from diametrically opposed
political positions even described you
know as enemies who had the ability to
come together in the peace process and
the office of first and Deputy First
Minister for one year developing a
positive good working relationship and
indeed a very powerful friendship which
has existed to this very day and the
coolster you even known at one point as
the Chuckle brothers that's despite his
rather fierce public persona what does
that tell us about the man behind the
image well I think that that tells us
that the MPC was someone who made a
great effort to once he decided to join
with Shenfield in government to do it
wholeheartedly and to do it with some
considerable grace and 3:08 idea that we
were in government together
he treated me with only respect and
friendship and I similarly made huge
efforts also to ensure that we sent a
very positive message to the entire
community by all of us and despite our
differences in spite of our differences
allegiances I we almost work together
for the greater good so I think you know
he was undoubtedly a remarkable
politician he and I were diametrically
opposed to each other for many many
decades but I think the peace process
which you know is 20 years old this year
had a huge effect on many many people
not least only in Paisley himself
whenever in 2007 he decided to come on
board
inclusive negotiations I think that only
in Paisley could have delivered the
union's political process for such a
transformative change which brought
about great change in terms of politics
and security in the North you know I
just think that has lost today as
something that will be deeply felt by
Paisano supporters of the peaceful safe
deed I mean and of course as a man he
was never afraid of making his views
heard just briefly if you will what she
made convinces for example when he
heckled the Pope well obviously myself
as a Catholic I didn't like that I
thought that it was a wrong thing to do
and hastily will go through IANS career
as no doubt someday they will go through
my career and they will record all the
notable events and instances
controversial and other ways but I think
today I just want to think of someone
who made a positive contribution to the
peace process who was very faithful to
that you know once he made the decision
to come on board and many times I
reflect that it was an awful party that
Ian wasn't thirty years younger